[Music]
[Applause]
like oh my god I just really want that's
your call
we are at Disneyland Paris for Halloween
and I'm gonna try and leave this froggen
thing so we'll see how this consumism is
amazing that's the Tower of Terror right
we are about to go into the Disney World
studio tour Disney dance studio talks to
you is it studio - getting us studio
yeah tickets tickets boom disclosure amy
has a cold she's unusually sound like a
man so we thought we had it all planned
out how we're going to get to France I
was going to go down to Plymouth to get
Amy Parham my influences like the little
tail of England and then we're gonna
drive back up to where I'm from in
Surrey and then get a train that took an
hour right but then we checked and the
train was three hours and we were like
crap when I gonna make it in time so I
was like okay I'm driving to the airport
and then Amy had to sort out some
parking so park-and-ride yeah and then
we had to run and we literally got there
like 10 minutes of spare we're like
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here it's like this is meant to be
you're thinking in my head I was like
maybe this isn't meant to be I'm never
supposed to go to France well we're here
we did
a hard life
[Music]
so we literally only really came into
this Park which is the sterilants to do
to go to Toy Story blew my hair way
they'll let me turn you around
[Music]
we're gonna go in this
Monsters Inc like non-stop and how good
monster thinking and she does Sally and
I love my croissants Qian it's like and
like we just found it all Monsters Inc
Cora so uh yeah a little big play right
now you a little bit ready go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
go how do you feel
and me being me I'm freakin freezing so
I bought some nightmare [ __ ] and
stuff and it brings me back to being
like my young
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't see it she scared you know
other things
[Applause]
[Music]
we're in Discovery land and basically
we're not really that big on rights I'm
not going to wait two hours for a ride
so we can awake for the Star Wars rights
to Star Wars is what we were all about
those like yes nothing that's what I
mean is getting you excited about sir
Star Wars is first and then we'll see
what the rest of the day has in store
for us
I just want to steal the Halloween
decorations and hamdeen so where is all
the Halloween stuff
Oh Jana fuss like it like
although I want to do that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we just went on a hyperspace mountain
and freaka was so cool I felt like I was
actually flying around yeah there you
see it lasted like 2 minutes good best
two minutes missile r2d2 here took off
her hat so she screams [ __ ] yeah I think
say just go
I can hold my way in anyway yeah that's
fine ain't always need a penis we'll see
what the Q's back okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
with the beer
okay Linux Oh dark either you look sharp
either
[Music]
[Music]
now this is more Halloweeny
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
he waved to me I feel like a kid
[Applause]
[Music]
some people wait finally found over
Halloween kind of stuff and I can be
here
never before Christmas music so I'm
getting excited is around here somewhere
but there's like let's go seize a little
well and finally there's some kind of a
spooky house around here and that's like
the only last Friday I care about
[Music]
and Amy's not a matter I'm excited for
this one study it's kid friendly so
she's excited it's scary
[Music]
it's creepy
[Applause]
friend goes like a parade
exactly Amy
[Music]
[Applause]
car pending star
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it has come to the end of the day we're
freakin not good but it's it it's a very
good day thanks for watching yeah we got
some treats for our friends at home got
some Walt Disney pasture
[Applause]
bye anyway a couple of the dairy being
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]